- The other thing too,
we should look at why
didn't the Red Wave come?
And we should be very
honest with ourselves.
There's a couple
different reasons why?
And I'll tell you.
Look, as leader,
I'm fortunate in
both terms we've won.
But could we have won
more? Yeah, we could have.
I had three candidates
in Pennsylvania
that overperformed
the Republican
gubernatorial candidate
by 2014 and 11 and did not win.
This idea that we're
just gonna pick whoever
and think we're gonna
win in November.
No.
The top of the ticket's gonna
hurt you below the ticket.
And this idea that we're,
it almost happens
that we're better
at attacking other Republicans
than standing up for the
policies we believe in.
(cheerful music)
- Hey, guys.
Let's give a very nice welcome
to the Speaker of the House.
(audience applauding)
- We did a press
conference in here
and it wasn't like you'd see
before like the members get up.
And we invited parents and kids.
And we invited parents that
had the challenges, right,
one was, you'll remember him,
the father from Loudoun
County that his daughter,
- Oh, yeah.
- He comes and tells his story.
But then you have a young
mother from Rhode Island.
Her child went to kindergarten
and all she wanted to know,
what's on the curriculum?
They said, "Well,
you gotta ask us.
You gotta put it
in written form."
She goes, "Well, okay. Well,
then I had 100 questions."
Then they had a
meeting to sue her
for she was asking questions.
It was unbelievable.
And you think at times
these stories that
they just happened in one
little place, you know.
You hear about that male
swimmer against the women.
Well, now when you start
having the discussion,
it's happening everywhere.
And so, we like to
bring more people in.
And the other thing we're doing,
taking our hearings
out of Washington.
We've had them along the border,
we've had them in different
parts of the country.
Make the committees go out
to listen to the public.
- You can make some
noise for that.
Yeah, yeah. There you go.
(audience applauding)
I also like the way
we started that,
I didn't even have
to ask a question.
You could just talk,
(audience laughing)
and I'll just sit here with
my legs crossed for an hour
and we'll make it work.
- We've been interviewed before.
- Yeah.
- He's like most
people in California,
he used to live there.
Now he moved to Florida.
- But I'd go down to his
house and we'd do a show.
- Well, let's start actually,
since you talked about
the parental rights vote,
which did pass, but not
one Democrat voted for it.
Five Republicans
voted against it.
Transparency, that's
all it was about.
And I find when I
talk to these guys,
I listen to my audience
that's what most people want
right now out of government,
whether it's the schools
or whether it's here in DC.
Just show us what's going
on. Be honest with us.
Don't treat us like children.
Are you shocked that not one
Democrat could vote for it?
And because I
can't go, you know,
more than a minute
without talking about
AOC, unfortunately,
that in her speech where
she was railing against it,
she called it fascism.
She called it fascism.
I take it, nothing's probably
surprises you at this point.
- No. You know
what's interesting?
And this is what people
have to understand,
and I've come to understand
now with these Democrats,
they're very extreme
in their beliefs.
I mean, think about,
in Congress, when you put
a bill across the desk,
H.R is the House
Resolution number, right?
And it gets stamped by
the order in which you go.
But the majority
reserves 1 through 10
and the Democrats get
11 through 20, okay.
So you can pick
what's most important.
Now, our number one
bill is gonna be H.R.1,
which we'll vote on this week,
and that'll be for energy
independence, okay,
the Democrats were
in the majority.
Their number one bill
was election law reform.
That they wanted
to rig the system.
That will make
taxpayers pay for it,
and have a Czar and all that.
We made the parents
Bill of Rights H.R.5
for a couple different reasons.
One, that's when kindergarten
starts here, five years old.
But it really had five pillars.
Parents should know what's
being taught in the school.
Give us the curriculum,
not make us go have to find it.
Send it to us.
And what books
are there to read?
They say, we're banning books.
We never said anything about it.
Just tell us what you
want us to read, right?
Shouldn't we know?
The next thing we sought,
we should know how do
you spend the money?
It's taxpayer money. What's
it being spent on in schools?
Is it going just
to administration?
Where's it going?
We wanna protect our
children's privacy.
Are they selling
the data, right?
We wanna know, is there
a violent activity?
'Cause what will happen is, a
child may be hurt on a campus,
but you are only telling
those two children.
That father, what
happened to him,
he went and told.
But the person who that
molested his daughter
had already done it before.
And the last part is, a parent
has a right to be heard.
You should be able to go
to a school board meeting
and not say you're a terrorist.
I'm a big conservative
federalist and all that.
That's not getting
in a school board.
That's just respect
in the process,
and that's just transparency.
I'm very big on transparency.
The Democrats try to
attack me all the time
when I provide information,
when they tried to only
show certain parts.
Well, let the public
make that decision.
That's the difference, I think.
When we had this dis
discussion before,
I was born into a democratic
family, but never a Democrat.
So, I really think my
philosophy and beliefs
are stronger than others
because I chose to reject
what I heard for
something different.
And what I believe in a
philosophy, I trust you.
I'm gonna give you
the information,
but I also trust you
to fail or succeed.
I'm not gonna predetermine that.
- So, I don't wanna
do just policy here
because I'm guessing,
how many of you, is this
the first time either in,
well, in the Capitol itself?
I assume many of you, right?
- Fabulous.
- Yeah.
So, how weird is it on
just a day-to-day basis
that you're in this
building right now,
where pretty much
everyone's here right now
for the most part, right,
and you're in this
building with these people
that the ideas are just
so diametrically opposed
with each other.
And you know, they say some
pretty nasty things about you
and you gotta say
some things about them
and sometimes they're on your
side of the aisle doing that.
- Yeah. No, no.
Look, if you follow
the Speaker's race,
most people win on
the first round, okay.
(audience laughing)
It's kind of a shock.
- He had a rough week.
He had a rough week.
- But you know what? I'm Irish
and Italian, so it's okay.
I have the best fights in
my neighborhood, right.
And most fights go 15
rounds. So, that's okay.
But I'll tell you a story.
So, if you watch
the Speaker's race,
there's this one staffer
who sat next to me,
John LeGansky, and
everybody wants to know.
He's a really smart kid.
He went to Stanford.
He was the youngest
guy ever run the floor.
And his brother's about to
become an ordained priest.
And his brother sent him a
book of prayers, you know,
before it all.
And he went and we
would keep a tally sheet
of everybody's name
that he'd keep voting.
And before the
speaker votes, right,
he just put a
handful down there.
And when the Speaker
Race was over, he said,
"You know what?
We always knew it
was gonna go to 15."
I said, "Well, how
did we always know?"
He goes, "You know, I didn't
get a chance to finish
all the prayers in the book
and this weekend I did.
You know, how many
prayers were in that book?
15 prayers."
He goes, "You know
how many ballots
I just grabbed a handful
of put down there?
15."
So sometimes God
has a plan for you,
you just don't
know it yet, right.
I could have been
Speaker before.
We're in the majority. It
was gonna be handed to me.
But I made a mistake
on a interview.
And lo and behold, pull back.
We went back into the minority.
And an interesting
thing happened.
So, four years ago,
I became leader of
the Republican Party
and Pelosi became Speaker.
We have a five seat majority.
And those four years, we
picked up six more seats.
Six Democrats lost
their congressional
seats in California.
No one writes about this.
She lost her majority
in her home state
that people think is
really blue, right?
But we were able to win.
If anyone ever wants
to run for office,
this is what I would tell you.
And how long should the
members stay in office?
If you don't get goosebumps
looking at that Capitol,
walking into this building,
it's time for you to leave.
Right?
I feel so privileged to even
have this opportunity, right.
I get goosebumps now just
talking to you about it.
Think about it.
We're sitting in the
Rayburn Room, right?
The chambers is right there.
Those chambers were
opened in 1857, right?
George Washington was
never sworn in here, right?
sworn in on Wall Street
and in Philadelphia, okay.
Every President since
has either been sworn in
on the east side,
over on the west side.
The first President be sworn
on the west side was Reagan.
He'd tell you he wanted to
look towards California, right?
But my favorite place
in this whole building,
if you go and take a tour,
is that room right
there at Statuary Hall.
So when the building
was first built,
the country wasn't 50 states,
it wasn't as large
people had desks.
This dome is the second dome.
They had to enlarge the dome
when they enlarged the building.
Like the Supreme Court was
over on the Senate side.
So that was the chambers.
And it's really a nice floor.
It wasn't thin.
It was platoons,
people spinning.
People had fights,
'cause this was before
the Civil War, right.
But they put a tile with anyone
who ever been a member of
Congress that became President.
So you could see where they sat.
So if you go all the way in
the back, there's a tile there.
But like Father Sierra,
there's a tile in front of it.
It's where Abraham Lincoln sat.
He was a one term congressman.
That's all he served.
And so he sat in the back.
And he was kind of a quiet man.
And if you go in the
back, back there,
they had like, a male room,
and we call it the Lincoln Room.
He'd go back there
and tell his stories.
But I like to stand
right where that tile is.
Stand there and look front,
like at the front of it.
Envision it being
loud, you know,
They didn't have
microphones on it.
And then look back and look
at the lady above the clock.
She's supposed to be
inscribing what happens there.
And just look at the clock
and pause and look
at the time, right?
Look at the time.
Say, oh, it's 2:30.
And you wanna know why
that's my favorite spot.
That's the same clock, the
same view Abraham Lincoln had.
And I'll promise you,
he's looked at it many times
and you're standing
right where he is, right.
Runs for Senate loses,
runs for President.
And this is one of the things
that drives me as a Republican.
He's the first
Republican President.
Here's a nation not even know
if it's gonna sustain itself.
He builds the
Intercontinental railroad.
That's like inventing
the internet, right,
during the time.
That he's looking at the
future's gonna be brighter.
But this is what I think
all Americans should pause.
Did you see that poll in
the Wall Street Journal
where we're not
patriotic anymore.
We don't want to have
children. We're not religious.
That concerns me.
And what I would say is,
look at Lincoln's words, right.
And what I believe if Lincoln,
if he was interviewing Lincoln
today and Lincoln was here,
Lincoln would first
take off his top hat.
He'd be a tall man.
He has a high voice.
But he would tell you
about the "Gettysburg
Address," you know.
"Fourscore and seven years ago,
our forefathers brought forth
on this continent, a
new nation," right,
"conceived in
liberty and dedicated
to the proposition
that we're all equal."
He goes on to say, "But if we
fail government of the people,
by the people, for the people,
shall not perish from earth."
But think about when he wrote
this and why he said it, okay.
We're not the world power.
We're not even a
country. We're divided.
But he knew America's
more than a country.
An idea that we would
still sustain ourselves,
the concept of by the
people, for the people
is more powerful
than anything else.
But name me one other nation
that's conceived in liberty
and dedicated the proposition
that we're all equal.
We're not a perfect nation.
We strive to be a
more perfect nation,
but we should be more patriotic.
I mean, this idea,
and this it goes long answer
to your short question.
I will put bills on the floor.
- I don't even
remember the question.
(audience laughing)
- I just now, Dave.
- I think I asked
you what it's like
to work in a place when
people don't like you.
- Okay.
So we had a resolution
on the floor
denouncing socialism, okay.
This is not a college
campus. This is not Berkeley.
This is people elected to the
US House of Representatives
of all the history of America
and 100 Democrats
couldn't vote, no.
Can you believe that?
So it goes back
to your question,
could I believe that not
one Democrat would stand up?
That's an extreme position.
And I say this with
all due respect.
The Democrats where I grew
up, they were not that way.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- You would find places here.
And look, we have passed,
I'll get this wrong,
in the last week,
we're somewhere about
43 or 48 bills, okay?
Over like 37 of them
have all been bipartisan.
There's been more than 4,000
Democrat votes on these, right?
And so, you can find common
ground with both sides.
But how can it not be common
ground that parents can know
what's being taught
in their kid's school?
No way do they get to
say what the curriculum
or what the books
are being read.
Just tell us what you're doing.
And that's wrong?
- So how do we get over that?
Because I think that that
seems to be probably the,
there's a lot of problems but
that seems to be the first one
that when you look
back and you go, okay,
well these guys
aren't, you know,
they are afraid to
denounce socialism.
Many of them do view the
founding of the country
as a net negative to the
world, things of that nature.
How do we get past that
before we get into
the battles of,
okay, you want this tax break
and you want that spending bill?
- Well it's tough too, 'cause
it's just like on DC Crime.
Now, all of you stay
safe here, but you know,
DC is not a State.
They wanna make it a state.
And the city council went and
decriminalized carjacking,
even forms of murder.
So we could do
something about it.
We put it on the floor to
not allow that to happen.
One member on the
Democratic side
got mugged on her way to work
and she lives in a
really nice area.
But it's not unusual, right?
You talk to staff, it
happens all the time.
- Rand Paul's, one
of his staff members,
- Got stabbed.
- was stabbed two days ago.
I think he's in
critical condition.
- The other weekend before,
in broad daylight in the
middle of the weekend,
had a gunpoint
robbed and the phone
and everything else taken.
Carjackings, we did
this in February.
At that time there were,
we had only about 30 some
days into the new year
and there were 65 carjackings.
When we passed this, the
President said he would veto it.
Only 31 Democrats voted with us.
That's not a partisan
issue to be safe.
- So, what is it
you hear from them?
What do you hear privately
when they vote against it?
- They think they
have to lock together.
That somehow, oh, that I'm
agreeing with the Republican.
No, you want your
streets safe, you know.
And they said, "But
DC should be a state
and we should have
our hands off."
Now, the delegate
for DC, Norton,
she did a rally before it
was gonna come back, right?
And she had it at Union Station
in the middle of the
day at three o'clock.
And if you watch the
video of the rally,
somebody gets carjacked
during the rally.
(audience laughing)
You can't make this up.
You can't make it up.
But this is the other thing,
and this is what scares me.
So, it wasn't just about DC,
it's about what's happening
across this nation in crime
from Chicago and others.
And I believe there
are some waking up,
but the majority are not
'cause they think they
can't stand up to them.
DC also says,
"Anybody can vote."
Okay, we're in pretty much
an international
city, are we not?
'cause you have all
these embassies.
So you can belong to the
Chinese Communist Party,
be a Chinese and work
at that embassy in DC
now said, you can vote
in your elections here.
What do you think they
would wanna vote for
and embarrass our
nation's Capitol.
That's what concerns me.
That's beyond common sense.
That's an extreme position
that goes beyond the
foundation of the nation.
- So what do you think
Republicans can do better then?
One of the lines that
these guys hear me say
probably five times a week is,
you don't have to
be a Republican,
but you cannot be a Democrat.
And the reason I
frame it that way is,
it's obvious they've,
for the most part,
gone off the deep end.
But there clearly is some
sort of branding issue
or something that I
think might be changing.
I do believe that,
that, you know, for example,
the Republicans obviously,
didn't get that Red
Wave in the midterm.
So people clearly are stepping
away from the Democrats,
but they're kind of, ah, I
don't know these Republicans,
- You know, the other thing too,
we should look at why
didn't the Red Wave come?
And we should be very
honest with ourselves.
There's a couple different
reasons why, and I'll tell you.
Look, as leader, I'm fortunate
in both terms we've won.
But could we have won
more? Yeah, we could have.
I had three candidates in
Pennsylvania that overperformed
the Republican
gubernatorial candidate
by 2014 and 11 and did not win.
This idea that we're
just gonna pick whoever
and think we're gonna
win in November.
No.
The top of the ticket's gonna
hurt you below the ticket.
And this idea that we're,
it almost happens
that we're better
at attacking other Republicans
than standing up for the
policies we believe in.
Well, that gets us nowhere.
And the other thing too is,
if you wanna be in the majority,
and this is what Reagan said,
"If you agree with us 80%
of the time, you're there."
Somebody who wins in Texas
is gonna be different than
someone who wins in California.
And if you wanna sit back and
where did we win the majority?
We woN five new seats in New
York, we won in California,
we won in Oregon,
we won in Arizona,
places that other
Republicans lost.
And to be frank, in
the last two cycles,
we've lost the presidency.
Both cycles lost in the Senate.
We've lost Governors.
The only place we've
won is in the House.
And the one thing I will
say, the determining factor,
the quality of the candidate.
We have an extraordinary
candidates who've won.
And sometimes it's
very important
to get the right person
through the primary.
And you shouldn't just say,
okay, well this person
is the most conservative.
Well, who's the most
conservative who
can win in November?
That's another
thing we have think,
because you gotta have
the gavel to govern.
The uniqueness, like we
have a five seat majority.
They don't hand the gavels out
in small, medium, and large.
We get the same
size gavel, and so.
And this is a place as
Republicans should wake up.
So I look back at
the vote saying,
where could we have done better?
Top of the ticket hurt.
Supreme Court decision
made a difference too,
in different places where
the Democrats played it.
It did.
- So you think it hurt more
than anticipated, maybe?
- Yeah, much more than
the polling showed.
It determined turnout
and motivation.
In 2012, we had 234 members
and we didn't even win the
popular vote in the House.
In 2016, we peaked.
We had 242 members and we won
the popular vote by one point.
Today we have 222 members,
you know what our
popular vote was?
We won it by three points.
Two points better
than the time before.
Seven points better than
we did two years prior.
So what it means is,
it's more competitive.
We've had redistricting.
So, it's not that you're gonna
have these big majorities
that you think things
are just gonna happen.
And people look through
different points, right?
I mean, think for a moment,
how many are you
from Pennsylvania?
The one thing I learned is,
Democrats will vote for whoever
as long as they're a Democrat.
(audience laughing)
You know?
But I will tell you,
- Where is John Fetterman?
(audience laughing)
Where is he?
- I don't know.
But I'm just, you know,
all due respect, I mean,
it's just very difficult.
But Republicans,
and this is where I say
we've gotta be honest
with ourselves
and we gotta do it
before you get to election,
if we have a poor
candidate, rightfully so,
we won't all walk and lock step
and vote for that
person, rightfully so.
So what we really should
do in the primary,
not beat up on each other,
but pick the very best person
who's gonna be able
to win and carry it.
And sometimes we
say, if you're not,
no one's gonna be
100% with each other.
But do we have a core
foundation with one another?
- I'll tell you guys something
funny about John Fetterman.
I actually saw Dr.
Oz a couple weeks ago
at Jordan Peterson's
house at a party.
And he looked like he
got punched in the face.
The guy cannot believe
that he lost to Fetterman.
It is still,
(audience chattering)
Any who.
What do you make
of, as you know,
I lived in Cali,
I made a very public exit to
the free State of Florida.
Things seem to be,
- I'm not giving up.
I'm not giving up.
(audience laughing)
- You know, I didn't
wanna leave that house,
but that was the only thing
that was keeping me
there was a home.
- I didn't wanna
leave that house,
but I couldn't afford to
buy that house there either.
- But what do you make
of the general idea now
that the states do seem to
be going their separate way
and that is what
Federalism's all about.
I mean, I feel like I
moved to a new country,
not a new state.
- Each state is a pilot program.
- Yeah.
- And if there's one thing,
you look in the nation, right,
every 10 years we do a census.
This is the first time in
the history of California
that we lost a
Congressional seat,
the time before we stayed equal.
And what states lost?
New York, California, Illinois.
What states gained?
Texas and Florida.
It's a pilot program that's
telling the country, right.
And how many, you have
friends that have moved?
Why? Because of the policies.
And it should wake the
other states up to change.
- I mean, do you have
any hope for Cali?
I mean obviously you're still
a representative in Cali.
I mean, do you have hope
that that thing can move.
- Yeah, because look,
I've won five seats in the
last four years in California,
Republican and Congress.
They make the system hard there.
The other thing you
have to remember too,
California has, when it
comes to election law,
they mail everybody a ballot.
Whether you ask for one or not.
They don't clean up their rules.
They make it legal that you can
harvest somebody's
ballot and we still win.
So it doesn't matter
what state you live in,
find what the rules are
and go out and fight
for what you believe in.
The hard part is,
most people who are
leaving California
have a more conservative view.
And you know, these
other states say,
"Oh, we don't want the Cali."
I want them back, you know.
They're a lot of
the other voters.
But we're learning.
And also the other thing too is,
if you look at the Republican
Party now in the House,
more women, more minorities,
the most Black Republicans
since reconstruction.
So don't think we can't compete
anywhere in the country.
We can.
But I believe it's the policy.
And so, I don't give up because
the pendulum always swings.
- How much do you view
the mainstream media
as an impediment to what you're
trying to do at this point?
They obviously are losing
control to a certain degree.
But, you know, every
day on the show,
I'm putting out the
lies of The View
and the lies of Meet The Press
and the lies of CNN and
MSNBC and the whole thing.
They're never with you guys.
They don't mind lying over
and over and over again.
Do you view it as
a problem still
or in some ways is it a win
because we can expose it now?
- Well, I think
the American public
on both sides of the aisle
do not trust what they're
being told most of the time.
'Cause they found
that it hasn't been,
there's lots of times
that it hasn't been right.
I live it each and every day.
I can walk up and do
a press conference,
I'll tell you on
right after passing
the Parents' Bill of Rights
and they'll ask me something
about something else, right.
But to tell you the secret is,
I kind of enjoy the battle now.
I don't know if you watch
any of my press conferences?
I decided when I
became a speaker,
I'm gonna do
something different.
And I do a lot of
things different.
Hakeem Jeffries'
office is right over,
that used to be my office.
But I treat Hakeem the way
I wanted to be treated.
We should be the first
ones that respect people
who have difference
of opinion of us.
Because we get upset
if people don't give us
the respect of our opinions.
Well, how can you do that
if you don't respect?
So, I try to provide that.
But I don't go down
and do a press conference
in the Press Room.
I do it in the Statutory
Hall, I do it out here.
And they all come around me
and they'll ask me
this one question.
When I was dealing from the
beginning about on intel.
I removed Schiff and Swalwell.
I did it for a purpose, not
for a political purpose.
And this one reporter
asked me the question
and then soon as
I start to answer,
she says, I'm not
answering the question.
So my point is,
well, you have a right
to ask me the question,
but you do not
have a right to say
whether I answered or not.
My answer is your answer.
But I mean, think about it.
I was really concerned about
Intel committee's different
than all the other committees.
This is where you get the
security clearance, okay.
The members who sit on there
only get appointed
by their leaders.
They find things out that
other members don't, right.
And we make decisions in
there to protect all of us
with information we know.
And because of
source and others,
you really can't let
other people know.
Well, Schiff used that position
to lie about what he knew,
which you can't be there.
Swalwell got on as a sophomore
and the minute he gets on,
the FBI comes tells us,
he's got a relationship
with a Chinese spy.
No disrespect.
I just don't think that
qualifies you, right.
(audience laughing)
- No disrespect. No disrespect.
- Yeah but,
there's 200 other members
she could appointed, right?
- Yeah.
- I never knew about this
until I came later there.
And I'm reading the papers.
I had the FBI come and
give me the briefing.
There's no way he should
have been on there.
And he was kept on there.
And so I just said, "No.
Anybody that has a
relationship with any spy,
you can't be on the committee."
(audience laughing)
I mean, it's not a high bar.
- Wait, I have to
pause you for a sec
'cause when I had you
at the house in Cali,
you told me about that
for the first time,
it was the first time
I heard about it.
And we then clipped
that a million times
and it got millions of views
and people were sharing it
before you were Speaker and now.
But he's still here. He's
still in this building.
If you have a relationship
with the Chinese spy,
no disrespect,
I just became very Italian.
Do you see that?
Isn't that just like,
you gotta go now?
Like you can't stay here.
You don't have to go home
but you can't stay here,
- I believe in the rule of law.
The voters decide who their
member of Congress is.
I could dislike that person.
I could think that person
did something wrong.
But there's nothing
that disqualifies him
from being a member.
He's a member and I
give him committees,
but I'm not giving you
a security clearance.
If he was to leave this job
and he went to the
private sector,
he could not get a
security clearance
because he had a relationship
with a Chinese spy.
So why would we give him a
government security clearance?
And they attacked before it.
And so what I did,
I went down when the intel
committee first constituted
and I had Hakeem come with me.
And I told all the members,
"Look, I want you
to work together.
I don't want partisanship
in this office
because this is a
committee that should think
just as Americans, right.
And this is the other
thing I'm doing.
I'm really afraid,
which country captures AI
and quantum first, okay.
And we should be really
concerned as Americans
of what's happening
with Russia, China,
North Korea and Iran.
If you study history, this
is very similar to the 1930s.
They're creating
an axis of power
of supporting one
another against the West,
democracy and freedom.
The only two times President Xi
has left his country
since the pandemic
was to meet with this group.
It's very concerning to me.
And so MIT teaches a
course in quantum and AI
that they actually provide to
the generals in our military.
I'm having everybody on
the intel take it together.
So they think like
a SWAT, right?
A strength, weakness,
opportunity, threats.
You think as an American,
not as a Republican
and Democrat, right.
Because whatever
happens if we fail,
it's not one party failing,
it's a nation that's failing.
And I'm gonna have 'em come in
and teach it to the
entire Congress.
You know, the only time
we really get together
outside of committees
and cameras
is when we have
classified briefings
and it's usually about a thread,
a balloon or
something else, right.
And so I recently had one
where all the
Republicans and Democrats
went together in the auditorium.
And you know what it
was about? Our debt.
And I didn't make it partisan.
I had the Congressional Budget
Office coming in and tell,
because this is what you
should be worried about too.
Look, we have a lot of problems.
We have a border
that's not secure,
we have fentanyl coming across,
we have inflation, all that.
But the three greatest,
biggest challenges I think,
to our nation going
forward is our debt,
our education system
and China, okay.
And we're not gonna tackle those
unless we tackle together.
And what I wanted to do
is not in a partisan way,
but really look at this debt.
The CBO tells us in
the next 10 years,
we'll have to pay 10.5 trillion
just in interest, okay.
But let me put in perspective,
10.5 trillion in
the next 10 years,
do you know how much
we paid in interest
since 1940 till today?
In those 83 years? 9 trillion.
This is the interest on your
credit card, okay, people.
This is what makes you upset.
And for the first time
in the next 10 years,
three of the trust
funds will go broke.
Highway, Medicare
and Social Security.
And the President all yells,
oh, Republicans wanna cut it.
No. By him doing nothing,
it automatically gets cut.
He's cutting it by
ignoring this problem.
And if you look at 50 year
averages, on 50 year average,
we normally spend
about 21% of GDP, okay.
Right now he's spending
23.7 on it's way to 25%.
On average amount of
revenue we bring in
on 50 years is
usually about 17.1%.
Do you know how
much revenue per GDP
we're bringing right now?
20%.
You know how many
times we've done that
in the history of America?
Only twice.
So, it's not a revenue problem.
We have more money at
any given time coming in,
but we're spending.
They added 5.9 trillion
and they wonder why
inflation was blah.
And what happened
when inflation came,
interest rates went up and now
it causes a banking problem.
And then he wants to
ignore the debt ceiling.
Like someone should just pass
that without changing it.
And to me, the debt ceiling is,
you give your child
a credit card,
they charge it up, you're
responsible for paying it,
but do you just raise the limit
or do you look at what
they're spending it on?
So that's the
approach I'm taking
and it's pretty hard that the
President tries to ignore it.
- Do you admire
sometimes the fact
that they can get away
with this kind of stuff?
I mean the Inflation
Reduction Act which,
(audience laughing)
- Had nothing do,
They even admit it doesn't have
anything to do with inflation.
- All right. I mean it
literally caused inflation.
But they get away with it.
The media runs cover for them
and then you have to come out
here and explain to, you know,
things about growth and
GDP and people are like,
"But the Inflation
Reduction Act."
- You know, you gotta
be strong-willed in this
and you gotta have a
willingness not to give up.
'Cause you could work
as hard as you can,
and they could say
something that's not true,
but you gotta wake up the
next day and come back.
You know, this country is too
great for small ideas, right.
And I just believe even
in the last election,
maybe it didn't turn out
exactly as you wanted,
but think about had we not
won the majority in the House,
what would be happening?
And sometimes we gotta thank
for what we got right then
and work harder.
That's exactly
what we have to do.
I'm thankful if you get
out and tell the story.
- We're trying. I
mean we're trying.
And what's interesting, I think,
that you'd find
from this audience,
if I polled these
guys, you know,
my audience is kind
of all over the place.
There's probably a
couple Democrats in here,
two maybe, maybe at most.
Democrats, there
might be two in here,
maybe not, maybe not.
A three.
You see that? Everybody
kind of froze.
Not me. Not me.
- There might be
Democrats who listen.
- Former, there are
definitely former Democrats.
How about former Democrats?
- That's all right.
- There's definitely,
- Ronald Reagan was
former Democrat.
- Right, exactly.
- [Audience Member] Positive.
(audience laughing)
- Let me ask you
about the hearings.
We're always watching hearings.
I'm always playing
clips of hearings
and we're dragging
out Twitter executives
and all of these people.
And Fauci, you know,
can lie about vaccines
or what we funded and
all of this stuff.
We play these clips
and people are like,
oh, it's great.
Rand Paul got 'em.
And this happened,
that happened.
Ted Cruz got 'em.
But then no one gets fired.
Nothing seems to
actually change.
And I think that that is
now something that you guys,
that's my personal
advice would be that,
that's something that you
guys should be focusing on.
Like, what happens
after the hearing?
It's not enough for
us to just be like,
oh, Fauci lied, Twitter
executives lied, et cetera.
- Okay, so let's
think about this.
Let's also look at
what has happened
since we won the majority?
We won the majority, we
weren't sworn in yet,
but we were able
to get in the NDAA
that those in the service,
no longer mandate that they
had the have the vaccine.
So they weren't
gonna be kicked out.
- Yeah.
- That's a victory, right.
So they stopped firing
people that there.
Is it a coincidence that
Fauci then announced
that he wasn't
gonna stay around?
Do you know something
else that we created?
We created a select
committee on COVID.
Is it a coincidence that
once we start the hearings
then they acknowledge,
well, there is information
that it could have come
from the Wuhan Lab of
the Wuhan COVID, right?
Who is the guy that used
to have the nighttime show,
the comedian?
- John.
- Oh, John Stewart,
he brought it to,
- Yeah, even he brings it up.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They named a lab after,
I think it happened.
(audience laughing)
It's interesting now.
Now they're providing
certain information
as we're going after it.
They make it very difficult now
that we have subpoena power.
But I think you'll find
at the end of the day
when we get the information,
now we're not gonna predetermine
if we don't have all the facts.
We're gonna take people
through and see all the facts.
Another thing that's happening
in this country
that's a problem,
there's no consequences
for people's action.
That's what's
happened with crime.
That's what's happened
in our schools, right.
And when they see it
happening in government,
then why should they not?
And I think that's
part of the point.
Ah look,
- So how does that
actually change?
I mean, do you need a
Republican President
to then do something about it?
So, let's say you
exposed these guys, okay,
Fauci lied under oath.
Let's just say, okay.
One of these guys,
- Is Fauci at a job anymore?
- Right?
So okay, but one of these,
or if we found out who exactly
at the government was guiding,
- We also changed
some of the rules
in the House when we took over.
So, I mean, it's hard for us.
Like, you get mad at somebody.
Okay, defund the
whole department.
Well, that doesn't work.
You don't have to defund.
Now we have a specific place
we can go. So, we can go there.
But what's interesting to
me, you brought up Twitter.
And I think Elon's doing
a fabulous job there,
to be honest with you.
And what Elon is doing,
not picking sides,
he's just letting
the information out.
And the Democrats are
getting mad, right.
But we watched what happened,
that it's even worse
than we imagined,
that government was
in with business now
going after people on
what their beliefs were.
But then he had some
Democrat reporters, right.
What happened to
Matt the other day?
The IRS comes to his house.
- Yep.
- So, sometimes our hearing
shows light stops actions.
We're not prosecutors.
So we can't prosecute somebody.
We can defund certain jobs,
but we don't have the
ability to prosecute someone.
We have the ability
to show the light
and give all the information
and also controls purse strings.
So we'll take every power we
have to try to correct actions.
- What else is on your mind
that may not be on our mind?
I mean, and by our mind,
I mean, the things that I'm
talking about on the show,
the things that these
guys are talking about,
like what else is
coming down the pike
that you're either worried
about or excited for?
- If you're not
excited as an American,
do you wanna live
somewhere else?
It may not be perfect here,
but we have an opportunity
to make it better, right?
So every day, I'm an optimist.
I wake up every day.
If there's the
one current thing,
I'm worried about
how the President's
handling the debt ceiling.
He's ignoring it.
He's walking us in to
some type of debt problem
because he's just
ignoring the problem.
I'm worried about
the next generation.
We're at 120% of GDP in debt.
We've only been here
during World War II.
That means our debt's larger
than our economy
with another 20%.
So what are you doing
to the resignation?
- So when you say that to your
colleagues on the other side,
what do they say?
I mean, do they
fundamentally just believe
you can just print money?
I mean, we've gotta print.
- Yes.
Because they've doing it.
- Yeah, they fundamentally.
That's the belief. That's
actually the belief.
- That's what caused,
look, Milton Freeman was
my favorite economist.
He says, "There's
only one entity
that can create inflation,
the government when
they spend too much."
And he also says, "There's
only one way out of inflation,
is that the interest
rates have to be higher
than the inflation rate."
Well, we can't afford that.
You're gonna be interest
rates over a 6, 7%.
It's gonna be gone.
Then I'm worried
about the future.
I look at these
other four countries
creating access of power.
I've watched what a lack of
leadership has happened, okay.
Think about when the
President got in,
Afghanistan, creating 13
new Gold Star families.
So, you know what? We
had a hearing on this.
For the whole time, they
never went and had a hearing
because they're afraid of
what they were gonna find out.
Why would you do
that to our military?
You wanna never repeat that?
He didn't listen to
the military leaders.
He made his own decision.
We actually had a sniper
that had the bomber
in his sights, okay.
But where did that
bomber come from?
Take it a step back further.
He was in the prison in Bagram.
So had he not moved outta Bagram
where we caught the worst
people for the last decade,
that person would've
never got out
and put a bomb on to
kill the Americans.
And then they wouldn't
look at the system.
But what happened after that?
It set us back two decades.
The Chancellor of Germany
now goes to China.
China has now just brokered
a deal in the Middle East
between Saudi Arabia and Iran.
That used to be the leadership
of America at Camp David, right.
So what he's done is,
he's lowered the
standards of America
to our allies and
to our adversaries,
pushing them further there.
It also brought
upon Ukraine, right.
Because then he goes
meets with Putin.
Putin saw what happened
in Afghanistan.
And what does he do when
he meets with Putin?
He lifts the sanctions
off North Stream too.
He gives 'em a welcome map.
Back in 2015, I met with
then, Vice President Biden,
try and encourage him to
sell the Javelins to Ukraine
so they can stop if any
Russian tanks come in.
He says, "No, Merkel
won't like that."
I said, "Well,
let's train them on
and keep them in Poland
so it's there close."
"No."
Remember when he spent too much
and he told us inflation
was transitory?
That's the worst punishment
you can ever do to
your own citizens.
It takes money
directly out of you.
And he told us it
was transitory.
Then the interest rates went
up, then banks got in trouble.
We're weaker around the world.
Then he comes out and he
picks one form of energy.
Makes our energy cost higher.
Cuts jobs out of America.
It harms emissions.
Let me tell you this,
American natural
gas is 41% cleaner
than Russian natural gas.
If we sell American natural gas,
not just to our allies,
to our adversaries,
global emissions
will go down further
than any Democrat
bill out there.
And you know what
else will happen?
Geopolitically, the
world will be safer.
They'll be more American jobs.
You'll have a
better environment,
you'll have a stronger America,
you'll have a safer world.
And he tells us, "I'm
gonna veto that on demand."
What? Makes no sense.
Don't you care
about the country?
Don't you care about the world?
And all he does is
empower his IRA bill,
Inflation Reduction.
That's a stimulus
bill for China.
Mandating one form of energy,
where are you gonna
buy the windmills?
Where are you gonna
buy the solar panels?
China.
And if you watch
what he's done is,
he's shut down our minerals.
China controls 90% of
all critical minerals.
They control 95%
of the processing.
So when we open up a
new mine in America,
we gotta send them over
there to be processed.
One thing we did do, when
we took the majority,
I've been wanting to
do this for four years,
I created the select
committee on China, okay.
The things that
we have failed at,
we have not spoken with
one voice about China.
China has systematically,
copper, key, and all these
renewables and everything else,
back in the 90s, we produced
three times as much.
They now produce
eight times. Why?
'Cause they've gone around
the world collecting it
while we shut ours down.
Why are we empowering them?
We shouldn't be dependent
upon them on anything.
We should bring it
back to America,
and back to just North
and South America as well.
And what he's done is make
us weaker on that stage.
And it's only been two years.
So what keeps me up
is that leadership.
- Who do you think
is driving that?
- He is.
- So you believe that this
is really Joe Biden himself.
(audience laughing)
- Now I get asked
this question a lot.
- Note how he had to
shift in his seat.
Yes, yes. Okay.
Sit up straight, yeah.
- I've met with him
a quite a few times.
It's him.
And remember, when he was
running for President,
he was about to be beaten.
They all collapsed, right?
And then he had to go
and publicly sign an
agreement with Bernie Sanders.
When he gave the
State of the Union,
one of my toughest jobs was
just to sit behind there, right.
And I was respectful. I
did not tear up the speech.
I could disagree
in anything else.
(audience applauding)
There's a difference
in speakers.
I respect the office, I have.
I respect his office. I
respect him in his office.
I heard Democrats yelling
to Bernie Sanders,
"You wrote that speech,
you wrote that speech,"
and Bernie's smiling.
Remember what he pledged,
to get their votes.
That's where he went so far.
That's the extreme position.
And remember, Bernie
Sanders is not a Democrat.
he's a socialist.
And he's never barked
away from that.
- Did you happen to see the
clip of Bernie on Real Time
with Bill Maher a
couple weeks ago
where he asked
him the difference
between equity and equality,
which is the entire
socialist program.
And Bernie literally
said, he didn't know.
And then Bill had to
walk him through it.
I mean, it's incredible.
- Bill Maher's been
pretty interesting.
- We're trying to get him there.
We're trying.
(audience laughing)
Do you you ever get the
call? You ever get the call?
- You know, I'd been
on that show before.
I was on that show,
before I was ever elected.
- What were you doing?
- I guess when it was on HBO
I was a young Republican, yeah.
Now, don't go back and
try to find the clip.
(audience laughing)
- But not getting
the call these days.
- Let's see.
Was it Diane Von
Furstenberg, the designer?
She was on it.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- One of the guys that was on a,
he had a hit show at the time.
And then I think a comedian.
- Well, what do you
think you gotta do
to get those last Liberals?
These guys know I
focus on that group.
'Cause I always say there's
not that many people
that can shift right now, right.
You have your
hardcore Republicans,
you have your
hardcore Democrats.
But I think the
disaffected Liberal
is the group that
you can still shift.
It is the Bill Maher types,
which is why I focus
on him so much.
Well, what do think
you have to do there?
- You know, we'd sit
back and we say like,
what am I doing to shift him?
I actually think the Democrats
are doing more to shift him.
I think if we ask Bill Maher
about me four years ago,
he'd say, "Kevin doesn't have
anything nice to say," right.
He'd say, "I don't
believe anything he says."
I think he's so disgusted
by these Democrat policies.
And what's really happened
is when the Democrats
took control of everything,
what brought us inflation,
what brought defunding
of the police,
what brought us crime, you know?
And then, they try to just
give talking points at that.
Like they're strong on crime.
Well, no, I mean did
you put anyone in jail
that was burning our
federal buildings?
No.
And what's really concerning
to America now too is,
we respect the rule of law,
we respect equal justice.
But when justice is only
weighed on one side,
that's what we don't like.
That is what gets us infuriated.
And I really think what
the Democrats have done
has moved Bill Barr
more that he said,
"This is no longer
where I stood in."
I really wonder in time,
if you look back in
history for many a times,
would John Kennedy
be a Democrat today?
- No.
- His policies are not where
the Democratic Party is at.
- Anti-war, low tax.
- Yeah.
- What would America
have looked like
had Abraham Lincoln not
been assassinated, right?
Malice towards none.
We wouldn't waited until
the 1950s to Civil Rights.
And this is something for people
who are Republican
and Conservative.
Don't let the Democrats
take this away, okay.
The Democrats had a bill
on the floor last Congress
to remove some statues.
I walked down the floor
and the Republican,
and I said, "Oh, I'm all for it.
I think you should
remove more statues
and I think you should
change your name."
There's not one Republican
statute we ever have to remove.
The Jim Crow Law was brought
to us by Democrats, okay.
Think about what
happened in my office.
You have a portrait
of Abraham Lincoln,
but you have a portrait
of Joseph Rainey.
Do you know who
Joseph Rainey is?
The first Black American
to get elected to Congress.
He was a Republican in 1870.
You know, when the first
Black American
Democrat was elected?
60 years later.
You know, Joseph Rainey
wasn't the only black
Republican elected.
A number of them were elected.
So then we had a Presidential
race that was close.
And so the Democrats
partnered with the Republicans
and said, "You won, but
only on one condition.
You removed the federal
troops from the South."
And when they removed the
federal troops from the South,
lo and behold, Democrats
then defeated Republicans.
And what did they do when
they defeated Republicans?
They changed the Election Law
and brought Jim Crow Laws in
and picked people based
upon who can go there.
Remember the Republican Party,
what it was founded upon.
So when the Democrats,
they removed five portraits
of Democrat speakers.
Okay. You should.
But every stature
they wanted to remove
was of a Democrat sent
to us from a state
that a Democrat majority
was in, that voted for it,
that was accepted by a Congress,
that was a majority
of Democrats.
Well, why do you
keep your name then?
Change the name of the party.
We don't have to change the
name of the Republican Party
'cause we were founded on the
idea that we're all equal.
We fought for the idea that
people were equal and fair.
And at times I've
watched when you say,
"How can you change?"
They don't know the history.
- Yeah.
- They don't know the story.
And we need to
tell it more often.
- So is that education
fundamentally?
I mean, is that
why we have to get
the schools back more
than anything else,
because people believe
now that 1619 project
was, you know, the true
the story of America?
- They tried to
recreate our history.
I mean, the idea
that Columbus is bad,
the idea that, you know,
you can't say Christmas,
I mean mean our founders
were some of the most
religious people, right.
We believe in re
religious freedom though.
I mean, the idea in our schools,
what I'm most worried about is,
nobody in the Taliban
or in the Chinese Army
are worried about a pronoun.
(audience laughing)
Nobody, okay.
With all respect, they
just wanna fight to win.
At the end of the day, we
may have the right pronouns,
but if we lose the
war, we're out, right?
And they only understand fear.
But also, the idea
of our children.
I'm not worried about my kids
competing with your kids.
I'm worried about our kids
competing with India and China.
And the great equalizer in
America is the education system.
And why it's the Democrats
who fight charter schools.
And this is the other thing
that's so great about states.
What Arizona has done,
what Florida has done
that allows your tax dollars
to follow your students
so they can go to
a better school.
It's your choice, you
know. That's gonna change.
And who does that help the most?
Really those who are
lower income in America,
and many times many more
minorities than others.
I'll tell you, today
I was very excited.
I had a school group that
was from my hometown here.
And it's a charter school
that was developed by this
one family, the Grimm's.
Any of you ever eat
these baby carrots?
Okay. They just sold.
But there was two
families in my district
that grew 80% of all the
carrots in the country.
And you want a secret?
There's no such thing
as a baby carrot.
They're regular carrots.
We chop 'em, charge you
more and you buy 'em.
We love you for it, okay.
(audience laughing)
- Goodnight, everybody.
- But what they
were doing is that,
they're a great
family, you know.
These families that
owned businesses,
and became a very big business,
well, they would put
all this money away
to give scholarships to
their employees' children
to go to college and they found,
well, you're not taking up.
Well, they weren't
getting into college.
They said, "Well, we
gotta go further down."
Well, they found the
school district with it.
So they were gonna pay to
put in a charter school.
The school district fought 'em.
But when they finally got
the charter school came in,
and this is 90% will be
immigrants in this community.
They wear uniforms,
they take extra classes, right.
And the thing I will tell you,
in the first two years,
this school scores are competing
with the highest scores
of anywhere in the county.
And we just had,
for the first time,
the eighth graders been there,
they just came and had a
picture with me in The Rotunda.
And the excitement
on these kids' faces
that one little girl stood up.
You could tell that she
was the class President.
She could ride up
on so and so on,
I want a picture of you.
And I'm thinking you're gonna
be Speaker one day, right.
I mean, but how
proud an opportunity.
That's the great
equalizer in America.
We talk about
everybody being equal,
but let's give 'em
an equal opportunity
and let's not hold people back.
- We got three minutes left
and then you gotta
get back to work.
So, I will ask you one
tough one at the end.
You've talked a lot
about civility here.
The audience obviously
knows my feelings
about what's going on in
Florida and Governor DeSantis,
Obviously, I supported Trump.
Trump supported you
in the Speakership.
This seems to be coming to
a head one way or another.
I've been concerned
about the civility also
because I don't wanna see
mutually assured destruction.
If Trump ends up President
and DeSantis stays
as my Governor,
that'll be just fine with me.
If DeSantis is President,
that'll be fine with me.
But I don't want to
destroy the whole thing.
And I sense we really
are in a dangerous spot
where we have a
lot of the momentum
that you've talked
about here and civility
and the right ideas and
things of that nature.
But it's like a
Tinder box in a way,
maybe because of some
of the personalities.
- I always think
we should do this.
Whenever I sit down,
like I was sitting down
with some members yesterday,
we were talking
around each other.
I said, "What do
we want to achieve?
Okay, you take everybody
out of running.
What do you want achieve?"
You wanna stop the bad policies.
So, you want somebody else
in the White House, right.
So you gotta understand too,
what's the debate
gonna be about?
All the things
that Biden has done
that somebody else
could do better.
I think that resonates
more with the public.
It gets more people to vote.
It's about addition,
not subtraction, okay.
And so it's tough when
you get in a competition.
But members should really
see that whoever runs.
And lots of times,
whoever the front runner is
today is not the nominee.
And whatever we think
the issue is today
is probably not
gonna be the issue
in another November from now.
But I think the
Democratic policies
will always be the issue, right.
And I just don't
think the country
wants another four
years of Joe Biden.
I just don't believe
we can sustain that.
And don't do damage
to one another
that allows him to get in
because they're gonna
give you a lot of bait.
Don't take it.
- Note, he did not
say Trump nor DeSantis
in that entire thing.
(audience laughing)
That was very slick.
Guys, please make some noise
for the Speaker of the House,
Kevin McCarthy.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- Thank you, my friend.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our Politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.